hi there today we'll look at distributed
representations of words and phrases and
their compositionality by thomas
McAuliffe Ilya sutskever chi-chan Greg
Corrado and Jeffrey Dean this is another
historical paper it's one of three
papers it's the middle one that
introduces the original word to Veck
algorithm and if you as you might know
work to back was extremely influential
in NLP since this paper basically until
recently where it's sort of gone out of
fashion a bit in research with the rise
of things like Elmo and Bert but it's
still a very very relevant so we'll look
at this historical paper today with kind
of the hindsight of being a couple years
into the future in fact as you see right
here this was released in 2013 so it's
seven years later now and we'll look
back and we'll see what they said back
then about the system this is not going
to be like a very you know well enhanced
PowerPoint presentation of how we're to
Veck works this we're going to look at
the paper and read it together
if if you if you like you know content
like this if you like historical paper
readings let me know in the comments
share it out if you do like it and of
course subscribe because this these kind
of historical papers I enjoy them but
you know many people might already know
what these things are so yeah ok
let's you know go through the paper and
pick up their ideas and kind of put them
in context they say the recently
introduced continues skip graham model
is an efficient method for learning
high-quality distributed vector
representations that capture a large
number of precise syntactic and semantic
world relationships so the Skip Graham
model was already introduced by mclubbe
in an earlier paper that came out I
believe not like one or two months prior
to this one as I said where to veck is a
series of papers I don't think there is
a paper called were to vector they here
have released the code along with the
with the paper in the code was called
- vac so the Skip Graham model was
introduced previously but it is
replicated right here so this in the
Skip Graham model what you're trying to
do is you're trying to get a distributed
word representation so what does that
mean that means that for each word in
your language let's take these words
right here for each word in the language
you want to come up with a vector that
somehow describes that word in a
continuous fashion so that with in a the
- like me might be mapped to I don't
know 0.1 0.9 and 0.3 Learn might be
mapped to negative 0.5 and so on so each
word gets assigned a vector in the same
dimensional space and what the previous
paper kind of discovered is that if you
do this correctly then these vectors
they have they have some kind of
properties and we can already kind of
jump ahead because this was already a
bit a bit researched in the last paper
the semantics of these vectors will be
something like this so here they have a
two dimensional PCA so these are the
first two dimensions of the one thousand
dimensional skip gram vector so the
vectors they obtain they can do things
like this where they can show that in
these spaces for example there appears
to be a vector Direction that
characterizes the capital of a country
so if you take a few countries and their
capitals and you average that vector you
get a kind of a direction for capital
Ness of a city given a country you can
see that there is a a pretty clear
relation here now some of these things
have later been revised to such that
they they are ultimately ended up being
not that impressive for example there
was always this kind of math with
vectors and I don't I believe this is
this might not be in this this is in the
last paper where they discovered that if
you take the vector for King and you
subtract the vector for man
and you add the vector for a woman then
that would result in the vector for
Queen so the way they did it was
basically they did this calculation
right here and then they searched in the
point they ended up they searched for
the nearest neighbor in their vocabulary
and that turned out to be Queen but in
order to make it Queen actually you have
to exclude the original word King and
people quickly discovered that if you
don't exclude the original word it you
know the result of this kind of
arithmetic will almost always lead back
to the original word and then a lot of
these analogy tasks are simply the
result of you then discarding that word
during the nearest neighbor search and
then Queen just happens to be one of the
closest words and it's it sort of much
less dependent on which exact
calculation you do here so there's been
a lot of follow-up work kind of
analyzing criticizing these vector maths
but definitely we know that these word
vectors turned out to be extremely
extremely helpful and syntactically and
semantically relevant in downstream
tasks because they have performed very
very well so how does the Skip Graham
model work how does how does it assign
vectors to each to each word so first of
all it has a dictionary so there is a
word an input word and for each word you
have a big dictionary and the diction
dictionary is basically says that you
know - the word - is going to be mapped
to this vector point one Dada Dada Dada
and so on the word learn is going to be
mapped to that vector and then you also
have these output vectors right here and
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to take a phrase from the data
set like this one right here and you
take out one word like this word vector
right here and you're trying to frame
this as a prediction task so you're
trying to frame this as in this case
four different prediction tasks so
you're telling your machine I give you
the word vector and which other words
are around the word vector you just tell
it that you don't tell it anything else
you just say which other words are
around the world vector and the correct
answers in this case would be to learn
word and representations so these you
construct for different training
examples where you have an x and a y so
the X is always vector and the Y is 2
and then the next training sample the X
is vector and the Y is learn and and so
on ok so this here each training sample
is a classification task right and the
classification task is and is as you can
see no you can't see right here but the
classification task is you have the
input word and you classify it into one
of many many many many many many classes
namely there are as many classes as you
have words in the dictionary
so each word in the dictionary will have
a class associated with it right so an
image nets you have like a thousand
classes but in these and that's already
a lot but in these tasks you're gonna
have a hundred thousand classes because
there are a hundred thousand words in
the English language that you wanna want
to treat and there are many more but in
this case they leave away all the words
that appear less than five times in
their corpus that's still a lot of words
so it's like a super duper duper lot of
a classification task but ultimately if
you do something like this
then the originally so the
representation that you end up with is
going to be very very good at doing
these kind of downstream tasks and
that's what they discovered so
their skip gram model is nothing else
than taking a word in predicting the
surrounding words from that word and
this is what it means this is the formal
statement of the skip gram objective
what you want to do is the objective of
the skip gram model is to maximize the
average log probability this one so for
the word we're considering the word t we
want to maximize the log probability of
each word W that is in around the word C
I'm sorry around the word W in a context
window of C that's exactly what we did
before we take a word like this model
right here and from it we predict all of
the words around it in energy in a given
window right that's all that's the
entire objective and that will give you
very good representations and this is
how you would implement that so what
you'll have is you'll have these vector
representation V that comes from your
original dictionary those are the things
you learn and then because you have like
an 30,000 way classifier you know that a
classification layer is nothing else
than a linear layer followed by a soft
max operation and that linear layer also
has parameters these are the the Prime's
okay so first you have the look up in
the dictionary for the word vector right
here and this is the vector of the
classification layer now there are
modifications where you can use like the
same vectors and so on or you can also
make use of these vectors but ultimately
you care about these vectors right here
and the vectors here are simply the
classification layers weights so here
you can see that there is what you're
trying to maximize is the inner product
between the word that you're considering
and the words around that word and
you're trying to do
a classification task so you need to
normalize now this is the normalization
constant and it goes over all of your
vocabulary so that's what they tackle
here they say W is the number of words
in the vocabulary this formulation is
impractical because the cost of
computing the gradient is proportional
to W which is often large and that's 10
to the 5 to 10 to the 7 terms so many 10
like tens of millions of terms in your
vocabulary that's just not feasible
right so people have been you know sort
of trying different ways to get around
very very large number of classes and
here it seems that that is really our
bottleneck in the previous paper they've
already shown that this objective can
give you very good word representation
but now we need to get around the fact
that we have such large vocabularies so
the first idea here is hierarchical
softmax and this is kind of a tangent i
find this paper by the way it's sort of
hard to read because it's like a half
engineering paper but yeah so first I
introduced this hierarchical softmax
which is kind of a a distraction it's
kind of a here is what we do here is
what we considered first but then didn't
end up using really they do compare with
it but the flow of text is sort of that
you expect this to be part of the final
model which it isn't so in the
hierarchical softmax what you do instead
of having this giant multi-class
classification task right here you take
all of these classes right here and you
put them in a sort of a tree okay so you
take this and you put them into a tree
so instead of classifying you know let's
say we have a thousand classes instead
of classifying a thousand ways we first
classify in two ways and then we
classify in two ways again from each one
and then we classify in two ways again
as you know a thousand is like two to
the ten so we need approximately ten
layers of this before we are actually
arriving at a thousand classes but it
also means that we only have to weigh
classifications each time so in the
hierarchical
softmax we build trees like this and
then we so we have a word we look up its
vector sorry its vector and then we
classify it for each of these nodes so
your output isn't going to be a thousand
a thousand log probabilities your output
is going to be a log probability a
binary log probability for each of the
nodes right here so you want to know
okay here is it in the upper half or the
lower half of my classes okay cool it's
in the upper half okay here is in the
upper half or the lower half and so on
and you learn all to predict all of
these junctions right here and that's
going to end up you with you having to
predict it less now of course you are
constrained you impose a very big prior
on the class distribution classes are an
independently anymore namely if two
classes here are in the same subtree
that means that they are going to be
predicted their predictions are going to
be correlated because the path to them
is the same partially so how you arrange
the classes here is very important and
there has been a lot of work in this but
as I said this is rather a distraction
right here hierarchical softmax is a way
to solve this however they went with a
different way right here they went with
this approach called negative sampling
negative sampling has been it's been
very influential not only in word to
vecna --get of sampling is one of the
cornerstones of the current trend in
self supervised learning in contrastive
estimation and so on so this all of this
you know it pops up in unlikely ways in
other fields and it sort of I'm not
gonna say it originated here but
definitely it was introduced into the
popular deep learning world
right here so they say an alternative to
hierarchical softmax
is noise contrastive estimation okay so
in noise contrastive estimation posits
that a good model should be able to
differentiate data from noise by means
of logistic regression you know that
seems very reasonable this is similar to
the hinge loss and so on yada yada
while NCE can be shown to approximately
maximize the log probability of the
softmax the Skip current model is only
concerned with learning high-quality
vector representations so we are free to
simplify in all these contrastive
estimation as long as the vector
representations retain their quality we
define negative sampling by this
following objective so this is very
interesting they see okay
noise contrastive estimation you know it
approximately maximizes the law of
probability so the noise contrastive
estimation would actually be the correct
way to approximate their problem however
they say well as long as you know as
long as something reasonable comes out
we're free to change that up a bit so
they go with this negative sampling
approach right here and you can see that
this is this is almost the same so it's
written a bit differently
from the original softmax thing because
the original softmax thing was written
as a fraction and here it's as a sum but
what you're trying to do in the noise
contain the negative sampling framework
is you trying to maximize the following
you're trying to maximize the inner
product of the word you're considering
and the words around them okay so if
you're trying to still predict the words
around you but now instead of having
this prediction soft max over all of the
classes you only have the soft max over
a subset of classes so what you'll do is
use sample words from your vocabulary at
random and you sample K of them and
you're simply trying to now minimize the
inner product between those words and
your
okay so what is that ultimately lead to
it ultimately leads to the following you
have a word like this word here- and
what you're trying to do is you're not
trying that much to predict the word
sampling what you're trying to do is
you're trying to say that in my space
right here I simply want sampling to be
closer than any other words that's not
in the context window okay so so here is
my word negative and here is my word
sampling and I want these two to be
close and if I if I sample another word
like here this is the word cake if I
sorry if I sample that I simply want
that to be far away further than than
the word sampling okay so this is now a
comparative it's not I classify sampling
as the highest class it's simply I want
to classify the word sampling against
the other classes higher all right
so and this is now much much easier so
instead of a thousand or ten thousand or
a million weigh classification and now
maybe have I have a k plus one way
classification right pretty easy right I
simply sample K other words and as I
assumed because I have so many words
chances that I actually sample one
that's in my context window is very
small right so I simply sample other
words and I say well these other words
are random they have nothing to do with
the current frame that I'm looking at so
they should be you know they can be
whatever they want but at least they
should be farther away than the words
that are actually in my in my
context and that is negative sampling
the process of sampling negatives this
right here and then making sure that the
positives which are these here in this
case the words in the context are
classified with a higher probability
than the negatives for a given in
right this here is the input word that's
it that's negative sampling and of
course yeah as I said you recognize this
from current things like yourself
supervised learning where you wanna have
the same image augmented twice go
through the pipeline
you know you augment you put a little
bit of different noise and then you have
a different image and at the end you say
these two should be close together well
this other one should be far apart it's
the exact same thing here except that
you have a different way of obtaining
the positive and the negative samples in
this case positive samples are
everything that's in the context
negative samples are just randomly
sampled from the data set and that you
know works of course that works much
much much faster and you can see that
this this turns out to give you vectors
that are pretty good and you can train
with higher vectors sorry with higher
dimensional vectors you can train with
bigger vocabularies with this this has
turned out to be very very influential
as I said now with the rise of Burke and
so on
work to back is kind of getting
forgotten but this was a revolution and
distributed vectors so it wasn't the
thing really it kind of was a thing
before that but it wasn't really a thing
that people used what people would do is
still they would do n gram models before
that so they would kind of diss diss
they would sort of chunk up their
sentences into engrams into overlapping
engrams and then have a big giant table
further where they index their engrams
so the word I don't know so the word
hello is ID 1 the word hello there is ID
2 and so on so you have a big table for
all the engrams and then what we would
try to do is you would try to do this
kind of bag of words estimation where
you would take a you know whatever
engrams appeared in
sentence and you would have this big you
know classification where you'd
associate the engrams with each other
and so on so distributed word
representations were kind of a
revolution at that point especially
distributed representation that actually
outperformed these old Engram methods so
there are a number of tricks right here
that are I think not understood until
this day for example the question is how
do you sample these negative samples
right right here this basically says get
K words from your vocabulary at random
according to this distribution right
here now how are you going to do that
basically you have a spectrum of options
the one side of the spectrum is going to
be completely uniform okay we sample
each word with the same probability and
the other side of the spectrum is
something like sample this according to
their unique gram these are two
different things
they're they're opposites in this in
this fashion so here you say hey some
words appear way way way more often than
other words shouldn't we prefer them
when we sample right shouldn't we if we
have a corpus and shouldn't we sample
from the corpus and if in the corpus one
word appears 50 times more than the
other word then shouldn't we sample that
50 times more as a negative because it's
you know so abundant and it should read
get a higher classification accuracy
whereas on the other hand you could say
no no we should simply sample every word
in our dictionary uniformly they came up
with something in between which they say
both NC and negative sampling have noise
distribution as a free parameter we
investigated a number of choices and
found that the unigram distribution
raised to the 3/4 power ie unigram to
death
recorder outperformed significantly the
unigram and uniform distributions for
both NC and neg on every task which
including language modeling this I think
is a mystery until today and it actually
turned out that this exponent right here
is magically much better than like the
exponent of one or even the exponent of
one half like you might be reasonably
assumed that the square root you know
might be something but the 3/4 I think
turned out to be very good and very
mystical so what does it what does it
mean it means that you have kind of a
balance between words that appear often
in words that don't appear often usually
in these kind of things you have a power
law where we have very few words that
appear very often and then you have okay
that's the tail shouldn't go up but you
have a very long tail of words right and
what you want to do is in this case you
want to sample these words here more but
they are they appear so much more often
than if you simply sample according to
their unigram distribution you basically
not regard these words right here you'll
forget about them and your performance
will suffer because they do appear every
now and then so what you want to do is
you want to push the dose down a little
bit and the optimal amount for the
little bit turns out to be to raise it
the you raise it to the 3/4 strange but
you know turned out to work well the
other thing they do is they do the they
do a sub sampling of frequent words so
again this is a way to kind of push down
the often appearing words where they say
the most frequent words can easily occur
hundreds of millions of times like in
the array such words usually provide
less information value than the rare
words for example while the Skip current
model benefits from observing the
co-occurrences of France and Paris it
benefits much less from observing the
frequent co-occurrences of France and
the as nearly every word Co occurs
frequently with in a sentence with the
so they do another trick here to counter
this imbalance between rare and frequent
words use a simple subsampling approach
each word in the training set is
discarded with probably
I computed by that formula right so
therefore formula right here and might
be asking again why why this formula so
this is the sampling probability of a
word and it goes with 1 over T T is a
temperature parameter and F is the
frequency with which the word appears in
the corpus so as you can see as the word
appears more in the in the corpus then
so this is the frequency as the word
appears more then this thing goes down
then this thing goes up so it's
discarded with this probability
so it's discarded with a higher
probability if it appears more often
where F is frequency if the word T is a
throat T is a chosen threshold which
shows this subsampling formula because
it aggressively sub-samples words whose
frequency is greater than T while
preserving the ranking of the
frequencies although this subsampling
formula was chosen heuristically we
found it to work well in practice it
accelerates learning and even
significantly improves the accuracy of
the learn vectors of the rare words as
will be shown in the following sections
so again something sort of arbitrary
it's even it's more understandable than
the 3/4 but still it's sort of arbitrary
they experimented around they found this
works well and then every everybody
ended up you know using that so that's
how this kind of stuff happens ok so now
we get into the empirical results and
the empirical results in this case we're
already sort of given in the previous
paper but here they have these the
analogical reasoning task where you can
see that the negative sampling did
outperform the others by quite a bit
right here
so the negative sampling approaches
outperformed the hierarchical softmax
and the noise contrastive estimation and
in the previous paper they also compared
with other baselines and saw that it
also outperforms those while being
right time time-efficient so you can see
that especially with these subsampling
approaches the time here there's 36
minutes for and they again I think they
have like a huge corpus that they train
on these were to vac code turned out to
be really really efficient code and
that's why I got so popular as well they
did the same thing for phrases right
here so for phrases like New York Times
and so on but this was kind of more of a
this was more of a side thing
the phrase vectors turned out to be you
know rather a side thing from the actual
code right here so yeah as as I said
this paper is very different from other
research papers and that it's it's sort
of half an engineering paper and all of
these papers are they're kinda hard to
read because they just kind of state
some things in the order is kind of
weird sometimes why they do things is
kind of weird sometimes but you can't
you know you can't deny that it had the
quite the effect on the community and
now this it is a very cool paper a very
cool series of papers and it's very cool
that actually they release the code and
they made the code such that it is super
duper efficient even like on a single
machine and that was very cool because
you know being Google they could have
just released code that is very
efficient on a distributed data center
and they didn't do that
so that this is it's sort of not really
like today anymore or like today when
they release code it's always you need
you need like 50 cloud TP use to do it
and it's still cool that they release
code but this was this was really a step
into kind of democratizing the AI and
yeah so that
was my rant about word to vac I hope you
enjoyed this I hope this still was
useful to you even though most of you
probably already knew were to back and
yeah so I'll see you next time bye bye